first marinade the thighs with soy sauce  and shouting wine which is made from  fermented rice and tastes similar to dry  sherry chicken thighs do a lot of work  so they need more cooking but cook  properly they're moist under the Tacy's  part of the bird next add rice vinegar  water and season and leave to marinade  for up to two hours  then chop garlic chili and ginger add  olive oil to a hot pan and fry until  softened add Szechuan peppercorns and  orange zest next add the marinated  chicken thighs along with a marinade  then throw in a pinch of sugar and fry  the chicken into lovely and brown and  the sauce is deliciously thick  finish with chopped spring onions add  lager soy sauce and a few drops of  sesame seed oil  the marinated for flavor sweet and spicy  chicken a fuss free wonder  start squeezing that garlic out want the  flavor coming out beautiful pierce that  open squeeze it in that delicious